[Musique]
parce qu'on vient nous rejoindre en
plateau avec michael me d'eurobonds soir
mais qu'elle vous avez fait vite alors
vous nous parler chaque semaine des
résultats sportifs du week end c'est une
traditionnelle chronique
alors il ya du football aujourd'hui au
coeur de cette chronique est direction
versailles on jouait ce week-end ce
dimanche le 7e tour de la coupe de
france
et oui grégory n'est versailles et ce
sont à qualifier pour le 8e tour en
s'imposant à domicile contre les
tahitiens de l' as dragon les deux buts
de cette partie ont été inscrits en
première période on écoute le milieu du
fc versailles oussama berkak au micro de
notre journaliste mélanie poké on est
satisfait de votre passé de passer le
tour c'est une satisfaction c'était une
chose qu'on avait à coeur de faire et
l'essentiel a été fait les deux buts en
première mi temps après on aurait aimé
marquer plus de buts en seconde période
mais bon tant qu'il ya la qualif au bout
c'est ce qu'on voulait je vous propose
maintenant de regarder l'une des actions
du match grégory anjou la deuxième
période et c'est à ce moment là que
marama vahirua l'ancien joueur de ligue
1 passé par nantes lorient ou monaco
réalise ce geste
regardez les déraisons pied 38 ans voilà
coup franc sur le poteau
voilà il ya des restes un vous l'avez
dit précédemment ça ne sourit
malheureusement pas aux tahitiens les
versailles l'emportent mais les
polynésiens sorte avec la tête haute
on a beaucoup travaillé mais notre
premier adversaire aujourd'hui c'était
quand même le voir et le vent donc du
coup c'est compliqué pour nous surtout
quand on vient ici en pleine période
chaude chez nous avec un taux de
l'humidité équipe à qui dépasse les 100%
ce sont des hommes avant d'aider
footballeur avec des convictions avec
cette envie
élevé de défendre lors leur île leur
identité et leur club le club n'avait
plus atteint 1 8e tour de coupe de
france depuis à 7 ans le tirage au sort
du 8e tour sera effectué ce mardi 20
novembre à 19 heures exactement les
versailles et pourrait recevoir un club
de ligue 2 grégory la rencontre se
disputera quant à elle le 8 décembre
prochain
versailles qualifié du coup mickaël est
ce que c'est le dernier club des
yvelines
et oui malheureusement versailles est
bien le dernier club en course dans
cette coupe de france l'aventuré
s'arrête donc au 7e tour pour carrière
gré sion le club qui évolue en première
division de district a été éliminé par
le charité sur loire
l'équipe de nationale 3 malgré les
quatre divisions d'écart le petit poucet
national s'est incliné 2 1 après avoir
ouvert le score à 20 minutes de la fin
du match par samir rivière une défaite
donc au goût amer à les yvelinois ne
rencontreront donc pas un club
professionnel dans cette coupe de france
merci michael cette information football
et bien d'autres encore à retrouver dans
votre émission le 7-8 sport juste après
ce journal